We Begin this hour with a rising star
who's lifting a lot of people with his
music
that's Noah Khan performing his song
stick season which has gotten more than
60 million that's right 60 million
Global streams since it came out in July
it's a breakup song filled with
heartache and it peaked at number one on
spotify's viral songs chart stick season
is now the title track on the singer
Songwriter's new album it was recorded
in written in Vermont where Khan lives
Jan Crawford recently visited and she's
here now with this Jan good morning well
good morning so you know Noah Khan
really broke into the music scene when
he was just 17 years old and he's
released several hit songs since then
now 25 Khan is coming into himself but
it took going back home to find out who
he really wants to be
[Music]
is going through a transformation in his
hit song stick season is the first page
of his new chapter
[Music]
what's it mean to you that song it's
about how things move forward you know
in Vermont fall it's beautiful and then
the leaves fall off the trees and it
stinks and then it's winter time and
it's pretty again I think the song means
so much more to me the Justice song I
think it represents a new path for me
and my career
[Music]
so we discovered life has changed a lot
for the 25 year old since he decided to
put off college and right out of high
school sign a record deal
[Music]
with hits like young blood and mess
[Music]
it's no stranger to success but with his
latest album stick season he decided to
take a risk moving full force into folk
music
when the weather gets bad if I was
listening a lot of your old stuff and I
mean it's definitely different sound I
think I grew up listening to folk music
and kind of narrative storytelling
songwriting the songs that got signed on
were definitely more pop leaning and I
wanted for this newest album to try kind
of paying homage to those artists I grew
up listening to who were able to tell
stories and I was living in Vermont
during the pandemic and I started to
kind of tell a story about being in
Vermont that's what I like about coming
here in a lot of ways I gotta feel like
a little kid Vermont's got that freedom
to up here in New England Khan spent
some of his childhood here in rural
Vermont a place he returned to during
the pandemic
I know that it ain't cool
he wrote come over a song on his new
album here on top of his grandparents
table in the living room of his mom's
house it's not like a writing room in
Nashville or a studio in Los Angeles and
there's like history here and there's
something innately familial about
writing here and I love that and a song
like come over then that's really
authentic yeah it's uh I feel like it
comes through like your environment kind
of
guides what the music sounds like
[Music]
his songs on Stick season touch on
themes like the difficulties of growing
up heartbreak feeling misunderstood and
isolated most of the songs are set in
Vermont and New England
[Music]
Thomas kind of realigned me with who I
was before instead of this person I was
trying to be out out there so being true
to yourself has enabled you to reach
people in a way that you may never have
been able to if you've gone to Nashville
or L.A yeah no it's funny like the place
that you feel like you were moving
backwards is actually the place that
sent me forward you had to go backwards
to go forward in a way I think like you
have to take stock of where you come
from and who you are and why that place
made you who you are in order to
understand yourself
Road
down the middle I wanted it to feel like
this drive the last song in his new
album called The View between Villages
is about the complicated feelings that
wash over him when he's about to return
home I wanted the song to build in the
same way that the drive builds I feel
this complete sense of Peace in the
first part and you know those lines like
pastel Brook Road I'm over the bridge
[Music]
Khan took us on the drive through his
town that inspired the song Here's the
bridge but it's the death of my dog the
stretch of my skin it's all wash and go
over me I'm angry again
better
the people I do
just these memories come back this once
you're in this place it's like it's
taking you right back to where you're
younger and then the last line is the
cars and reavers
[Music]
between everything still
the music dies down and it kind of feels
like that piece again why do you think
your music is really resonating with
people a lot of people have told me is
that they feel left behind they feel
scared they feel burnt out and people
have said that you know the biggest
company I've received I was able to
articulate something that they weren't
able to articulate that they felt within
themselves do you think that your music
is especially resonating with people of
your generation because of social media
because everything is it's fake a lot of
it yeah but like your music is real your
feelings that you're expressing are raw
and painful and Universal I think I
forgot things I've done Good to Be Alive
I believe that people resonate with
someone just presenting their truth in a
really raw way
a minute of my time
I don't miss you part of Khan's truth is
that sometimes he struggles he's been
open about going to therapy to help deal
with depression and anxiety I've come to
learn that like depression and anxiety
are going to be parts of my life forever
I do what I can to treat the symptoms
but it's still in there and having music
has been really important for me Khan
says right now he's in a good place and
he's excited that the music he feels he
was always meant to make is finally out
in the world when I was growing up that
I listened to a person sing about
something that I was feeling like I felt
like no one in the world that ever felt
that before and hearing someone say it
was the most gratifying thing in the
world my greatest goal is to do that for
other people to kind of provide that
Lifeline for somebody else is the
ultimate goal of me as a songwriter
foreign
[Music]
now the second single of Khan's new
album you heard it there at the end is
called Northern attitude and it's
already hit more than six and a half
million streams on Spotify his tour just
started and most shows are sold out of
them will be after hearing that oh yeah
of course and I love what he said he
said it's not a writing room in
Nashville this is in a studio in La
um this is home and you know the the
meaning of sticks it's layered of course
but it's like he's he's going exactly
where his roots are and remembering
where you came from right and then
building on that to find your true self
and I think that's why his music's
resonating with this generation trying
to find your place in a world that seems
so uncertain yeah I feel for this
generation because they are really stuck
in between they're so they have to have
all the answers well we're always told
When We're Young go chase your dreams
yes your dreams then you realize you're
chasing something that isn't able to be
touched this is like an intangible item
that we can't physically touch and then
you realize you're just running right
right right so returning home is amazing
Jan thank you for returning to the table
yeah
good to see you in person thank you